hey guys welcome to awesome comics your
one-stop shop for everything in comic
book entertainment I'm your host today
Ayanna Wade and we're here with a couple
of special people for today's episode
about hmm who are you gonna call well
I'm gonna calling you first better Phil
I really liked it yes it's not perfect
film although in my defense no film is
perfect and if you think a film is
perfect
that's not statistically possible by its
Princess Bride perfect film but I really
enjoyed it I think I had more fun what
the experience of watching it then just
judging the movie on that's pure merit I
had so much fun watching it I was
laughing I was smiling I was identifying
with the characters I had a great time
awesome awesome we're here also with
Heather hello Heather actually not have
a ruse any more recent recent upgrade in
the name so what do you think of the
film oh you have time between here win I
have you follow me on twitter you saw
this but like I we literally got off the
plane from the honeymoon I was like why
I had to go see Ghostbusters right now
basically if you're not doing that I
don't know what you're doing what's the
point but ok I thought it was okay I
mean it wasn't fantastic but it wasn't
terrible it was just kind of like it was
good it was good I should it was a
little bit better than me but it was
good okay more positive than negative
you'd say yeah C + B - maybe well let's
head over eat you I'm the token guy wait
we are guys No
not allowed sister thank you okay all
right all right deputize you thank you
thank you no I'm just kinda she said I'm
on the okay
board leading more towards positive I'm
glad I saw this movie I liked a lot of
the jokes I felt like the kind of
continual pattern that kept going on was
something funny what happened I laughed
really hard at and there's something not
funny would happen and that just kept
going and I wish it was all funny but
the funny stuff I thought was really
good I like the characters I like the
creativity I wasn't down for it being a
reboot because I am one of those I love
the original Ghostbusters I think I
agree there's no perfect movie that's
about as close to a perfect movie as you
can get but when I start watching it I
liked how it was sucking me and I liked
it more and was doing its own thing and
not trying to do callbacks to the
original which it does do but I didn't I
didn't feel like it was replacing I felt
more like this is like a parallel
universe where it's like these
ghostbusters can also exist and it's
kind of like when you see Christian Bale
as Batman that doesn't erase the Michael
Keaton Batman yeah you know I really
felt like this is just it was not a
replacement I thought that was really
good I'm glad they did that and I liked
it one was being more its own thing when
they did the callbacks I didn't like it
but I thought it was funny enough and I
would honestly see it again maybe I fast
forward a few seasons by yeah I love the
movie I really did I've also been
waiting for this movie my entire life
I loved the original Ghostbusters and
grew up with it have my flight suit over
here I loved Ghostbusters guys so yes I
was super stoked to go see it and yes
super stoked about female ghostbusters I
know that comes as such a shocker but I
I would agree that they they did so many
cameos that there was almost like to a
fault like it was nice to have the
little callbacks nice to be like oh
that's that's so cool you know but but
it would have been nice to save a couple
of them for
than sequel right which I'm hoping
happens and I'm hoping it does well this
weekend we'll find out you already know
before we have the results of opening
weekend so we were not quite sure how
well it did but as you can tell it did
awesome
it also brought and see it again please
know I would I would say that it
definitely has a rewatch ability
thankfully and yeah I thought it was a
really funny movie let's let's maybe
talk like positives what we liked about
the film and then we can get into like
negatives who favorite characters
Holtzman okay we can install the movie
for me yeah stole the movie they kind of
really play to her strengths Paul Feig
kind of like does a lot of improv on set
though too which when you have a cast of
SNL characters you know that really
helps when you get to work with actors
like that anyone have a favorite
character certain moments definitely her
I felt like that that was like the one
character like even in the trailer it's
like the people that hated the trailers
I didn't like the tree always very much
but everybody pointed her it's like she
looks cool like you know she looks funny
she looks a little crazy and stuff and
she is the cool gadgets and she says
just the insane stuff but if word ever
went too far like the only thing I think
of is like bebop and rocksteady Ninja
Turtles to where it's like oh shut up
you know every time she said something
I'm like okay I am totally down for this
I am totally happy whenever she opens
her mouth so yeah every single time she
was on was great and I might be I don't
know if I'm on you know like if I'm one
of the people then there was gonna be
like yeah ooh I like the Slimer cameo in
this I felt Swiper did what he was
supposed to do
go on a bender you know cause trouble he
steals a car which is amazing I mean I'm
just like Slimer steals a car that's
just the cool thing about her she's
pretty much the Neil Patrick Harris room
Harold and Kumar Go to White Castle okay
in this and that's why I love that's
what Slimers should do female Slimer was
weird
I kind of wish more ghosts had done
their thing it's like the only of Slimer
and then the random buddies that he
grabs when he's driving around but all
the other ones are just like menacing
ghosts if you didn't see any other
ghosts just hanging around except the
flasher I'm like okay go splasher I did
like careful when you turn the page that
was a little weird but at the same time
it's like Etsy that's what you do we
just go find some ladies and just go and
like crazy and stuff but yeah just the
one with the wig of stuff like yeah it
just makes me more curious like so okay
not only do these snot balls exist but
they must have died there's more than
one
I am so curious the origin of these
things they almost put an origin story
in the Ghostbusters movie but I think
they cut it out well ah but where are
these monsters coming friends just like
Zoolander but it's a queer thing coming
from I never knew the demon ghost the
like dragon ghost or whatever whatever
they just all these monsters you just
assume they died right there we have no
idea where they came we haven't talked
about the ghost that had or the animal
creature thing they had to die to become
some weird whole dimension
I also liked Chris Hemsworth I thought
he was really really funny I used to be
even more music roles he was just on
point well even as Thor he has this like
little moment source of comedy honestly
sort of plays kind of the straight man
in the comedy in this it was I did not
give him enough got it yeah there's one
or two times where I'm like like when
something's really loud he's like oh
that's loud that love is
okay vissa even babies know this like
sometimes he's a little too dumb but I
thought there was so much or nah he's a
little nearsighted yeah I loved when he
drove up and he's like in the outfit
he's because he what I loved was he
wasn't cocky he was a jerk he was just
really dumbly naive and and wanted to
help he's like I can be a Ghostbuster
yeah I got my motorcycle he had to go to
get it decorated I wish you a little bit
more agency though like I understand he
was just kind of there like switch up
the trope like he was the dummy but like
I can do much didn't have any agency and
then even when he did we already knew
about it cuz the trailer spoiled it yeah
boilers by the way that the trailer
already gave well let's be fair I think
we can all probably agree because it
looks like a lot was cut out of this
movie like there's a lot Caesar ridges
chopped but I think the best cut if my
opinion was the dance number that they
clearly shot with Chris Hemsworth and
they only they just played in the
credits I'm like I totally killed the
tone I'm not gonna if I saw that
actually in the film and then I would
then like don't walk out don't know it
was weird though to set it up in the not
move it was it was like they set up that
like he has this power to control
people's bodies but like I'm just not
gonna use it and we have a whole scene
while everyone's standing like this and
I was like so where's he going right I
mean I guess they couldn't reach you
right cuz that was when the women come
in the Ghostbusters come in and
everyone's like that so I'm guessing
that a lot of extra their way around
yeah yeah it's a little play just to
have them like this I mean it's a little
cute but then what you see what they're
gonna do in the end Chris
really really likes that end credit
sequence in general that I think we move
yes I also saw this in 3d and the
credits in 3d is awesome they have it in
like just letterboxing so when you watch
it like things go past yeah like when
the goes ba masters and it'll shoot past
the panties necklace also goes outside
there I thought they were pushing what
she's like slapping her there's just a
little panty like what's going outside
the box I'm just like what's that really
needed that was so much I really liked
Patty's care yeah I awesome I feel like
they did not shown her properly in the
trailer there were concerns that she was
going to be a stereotype eat wise black
woman but there was more like a
historian and historian than just a
streetwise person she wasn't like I know
the streets she was actually giving
historical lessons about the different
buildings like she clearly loved the
city and I felt that as the movie went
on she gelled with the other team
members the Ghostbusters and by the end
she was working the machine for the
spoilers post and yeah like she was
learning and she gelled with them and I
love Leslie Jones and I thought she was
great
yeah she's hilarious well I think what
people miss - is there like what how
many watch SNL or not is when they see
her in that role they're thinking like
oh oh who's this person doing the
stereotypical thing that's kind of her
thing it's like bringing Chris Rock and
to be like why is he yelling and I agree
with you with her knowing everything
because I think because of her job as
well you see she talks everybody she
gets info and stuff and so she would
know all about the city and she travels
underneath all the time so I think that
kind of makes sense yeah I think the end
fight sequence was also strong all the
ladies were strong but again my lady
okay we can an awesome awesome and fight
sequence it was really good
action-packed I know we were talking a
little bit before before filming about
ghostbusters one and how ya know that's
something cuz I I love the first one I
like this film I don't think anything is
technically better
the first film except I think the action
sequence is legitimate action because I
never put together the Ghostbusters all
the ghosts are flying around these are
just for comedians standing there
holding a stick and the big climax is
they point the sticks together that's
like the big scene with this one they're
flipping around they have these new
gadgets they can use them as webs they
can slide under them they can punch the
guy like I love that they added all this
stuff and I wrote but that was missing
in ghostbusters to which I I like this
no more than Ghostbusters 2 I'll just
say it I said I don't know I thought
this was more positive and rewatchable
even getting through the bad jokes it's
like but the good jokes are so worth it
yeah and I thought that was something
where it's like in ghostbusters 2 you
wanted to expand you wanted to kind of
go to the next level and they don't they
do it's huge step backwards and here I
really felt like they were sort of
trying new things and the worst parts is
when they did do those callbacks and
they did go back to a lot of the
celebrities coming L and their Stay Puft
and stuff like that you know I felt like
most of those were really distracting
for something night but what's doing ok
on its own yeah yeah I liked the parade
of the the balloons cuz you also that
was an interesting like they're they're
calling back to like these old parades
and you see it like the ghost like
recreating it and then they come and
attack and then you got to stay for sure
why are you here there's no reason that
Matt would not have existed there I'm
pretty convinced of this now I think
that it was put in there so that they
can release a picture I think it was the
movie trolling everybody cuz everybody's
like did you see Stay Puft oh my god did
he look awful and it's like it's a
balloon but everybody thought that was
going to be the real Stay Puft coming in
it's got you know it as a lanova
attention but it's a trolling movie the
weird thing I thought though I liked the
new gadgets a lot I thought they were
really cool designer but are we we're
killing ghosts yeah I do it the chipper
the ghost chipper or whatever I was
confused why that was ok olace anything
will kill the ghost and even the
inconsistencies in the tech - yeah first
they were doing it to rope them in and
they're using troponin on Olson it's
like cutting ghosts
and while they were taking them and
flinging them to the side yeah where
were they going I always assumed when
they were gonna come back right just
traps everywhere yeah they weren't like
cuttin happen dissolving though as
Melissa McCarthy was walking away they
were finding peace move on go away from
here I did take a quick second to talk
about Kristen Wiig and Lissa McCartney
yeah because I actually really liked
both their characters and I especially
liked all the four characters and how
they gelled together
yeah the relationships were really
strong I thought Melissa McCartney was
so optimistic and just so enthusiastic
and loving what she did and like no one
could make her question what she was
doing and I thought those were I liked
seeing her play a straighter character
Kristen Wiig I felt she could have amped
it up just a little bit at times but I
liked her but she added the four of them
she was my least favorite mm-hmm she
didn't really get to like do her normal
weird like you be her Ryan but target
lady you know like because we already
had a character like that I will say one
of the funniest moments though is after
they come out of the mansion and she's
covered in slime she's like oh my god I
believe this ghost and then you see it's
a video and she's just like the rest of
the movie have marketing like that
that's a genius let's talk about the
marketing for a second or lack thereof
there's where's all the I can buy
ecto cooler is still available thank you
very much that's oh baby it's not the
morning thing everybody I talked to it's
like it's good this looks IRA got like
to pay me I'm sad I haven't found any
like sure it's a target
there's no like posters there's like
there's the pop vinyls but those are
still kind of hard to find and they
release those like super early before
people like really cared who these
characters were you know I don't he's
scared of it honestly even the last
advertisement they have I mean again
just how badly they've been marketing
this it's like they were quoting like
New York Times or something like then
they're like you know says that this
movie dazzles as amazing and yes it has
girls get over it and I'm like you have
no idea how to do what's wrong you know
come after us come and Ebro we no no no
don't yeah and I felt like the whole
movie almost suffered from that like you
could tell it was almost like they were
afraid to leave certain things that are
they related someone came in from Sony
and was like you know what this needs
more Ghostbusters cameos like it was a
forester like a little timid things work
hey guys it's Heather as I'm sure you've
noticed I've been absent a little bit
for the past month or so and that's
because I got married yeah we did a lot
of crafting but one of the things that I
did is I made my whole bouquet here out
of sheet music comic books and old manga
so I'm going to show you quickly how to
make one of these flowers it takes about
10-15 minutes when you get really good
at it 10 minutes so it's nice you have
to take a comic book I know it's gonna
hurt you on the inside but you got to
cut it you got to cut it up you can do
six by six squares was what we use for
the bigger flowers five by five or four
by four for some of the smaller ones so
just cut them into squares like this and
then you got to fold the square three
times so if this was my square I could
go one two and then three so you get a
little triangle like this keep the
folded point at the bottom then you have
to cut it into a petal form since we had
to make a ton of them we actually had a
little mold here to use you're gonna
have to cut off a little bit of the tip
there no problem because it is gonna
have to nestle inside itself and then
just kind of get yourself a petal shape
it helps to give yourself a little bit
of leeway because you're gonna fold them
over because petals are not straight in
nature until eventually it'll look
something like that or I have another
one right here it'll look like that to
make one flower you need three of these
so at the end when you open it up it'll
look like this basic flower template
there you need three of them so on one
of them you cut out one petal so now
I've got one petal cut out of that one
there on another one which I've already
done you'll cut out two petals and then
guess what on the third one you'll cut
out three petals so it's not that hard
okay with the bigger ones you have to
take the hot glue and just make it into
a circle basically
gonna start with my biggest one here
you'll want the petals that you want
facing outward because color does matter
when you're putting it together you'll
want the ones that you want to show
facing inward like that so I want the
purples to show cuz I like the Purple's
in this I think it'll go well with some
of the blues that I have in this one
then all you're left with are these
little ones the three the two and the
one with the three it's gonna fit
together almost like a puzzle so if I
put it like that and that and I'm gonna
glue it like that so it's still similar
to what you've been doing with the
bigger ones but not quite so it almost
looks like the folded up pedal when you
have it like that but on the inside
again on the inside is what you want for
the ones that you want the color you
want to show so on my inside pedal I'm
gonna have spider-man that's what's
gonna show up with the one pedal you're
gonna kind of roll it up tight cuz this
is your Center this is your center piece
so if I roll it up tight kind of like
rolling a cigarette not that I know
anything about that guy's nothing it's
easier to put the glue just on the edge
it's also easier to use a low temp if
you have that option a low temp hot glue
gun a lot of my friends who help me
we're using a high temp and we had some
burns but they healed before the wedding
and that's all that mattered I put mine
on stems because I did eventually put it
inside of a floral foam to make the
actual bouquet itself if I hold it to
make the decay itself it's on floral
foam so I put it on stems
to do that was really easy just put a
little hot glue gun glue at the tip here
and it can dig that there let it hold
and it will set on the stem then I just
took regular 18 gauge pre-wrapped floral
stem because it was easier than trying
to wrap it itself with this one the two
one you're also gonna do the same thing
of rolling it up but you have to make it
a little bit bigger because it's going
to go on top of the smaller one this the
one one's gonna go inside of it so again
put it on the edge don't kill your
fingers low temp is better mine's a nice
one from Home Depot great place to buy
glue guns never knew that now you know
so then you put this bigger folded one
inside the smaller folded one glue it in
place again make sure it's glued here so
that doesn't just fall off a couple of
my friends we're doing these and helping
me and they didn't quite make sure this
stuck to the bottom and then they just
felt right off the stem so make sure
it's actually glued to itself with these
flowers in nature are not straight up
and down like this so you can take a
little pencil or I was also using
chopsticks to roll the edges so that
they get that nice Bend to them so it's
not just a straight up-and-down flower
and you'd be surprised how well the
comic books actually holds this curl
you wouldn't think they would but they
do hold it pretty well and then
basically are you gonna do once they're
all rolled and ready is just constructed
put it inside itself one layer at a time
until it looks like a flower
there you go like I said you have to
make sure that you actually get the glue
on there it actually touches base but
you also don't want to squish it too
much or you lose some of the flower
element of it next layer so on and so
forth and before you know it you're
going to have enough
hours to make a bouquet like this so
thanks everyone for checking out how
these are made I'm gonna finish this
flower just a little bit but back to you
guys at the studio I mean we have just
about everyone in the series in there
right they poured them all in there's
literally a scene where someone says I
ain't afraid of no ghosts
oh that was that was and there's a bad
cameos in the movie that was little I
was like Annie Potts was the my favorite
I think it's they put a little so there
were I mean I hate to be that person
that's like there were too many cameos
but I liked the cameos but they were
Sund that I thought were legitimately
funny and really like there were
collective like Oh in the audience when
you go see it everyone's like oh yeah
it's so ever it is but then some of them
were a little cheapened by the way they
kind of presented them a favor was
actually Bill Murray's oh I got X cubed
too long and they didn't give him enough
to do he gave ya one thing to do and you
just kept doing it until he got thrown
out a window what happened did he die I
thought I did we get a Bill Murray ghost
yeah I got excited when he showed up I
was actually like oh okay cuz he's gonna
be the skeptic and there's anyone that's
a great skeptic that can say he's gonna
be great ants like so is this real no
and I'm waiting for him to go in to make
up stuff like improvise whatever all the
things we you can see the strings there
and this is obviously very bad CGI like
have him make fun of it but just like no
cut and they she shows up again okay
well now they're gonna make up for that
it's just playing
I guess straight I don't even know what
he's doing and he's just gone I was with
you I was waiting for ghosts
Murray to pop up never did and yet to me
that's the most wasted one
mrs. slime slime er they would have Bill
Murray's wouldn't have been so much
better I'm on top or so we've already
got four female Ghostbusters we don't
need a female I know you like Slimer but
as far as negatives my least favorite
female slammer I yeah it felt like yeah
we got a girl felt like mrs. pacman we
were fine with flamer flamer i think
because i grew up with the cartoon and
to a point where Slimer actually took
over the cartoons like Slimer and the
Real Ghostbusters and then you saw the
Ghostbusters to just are going I felt
like because somebody said Oh Ivan
Reitman or somebody said he was supposed
to be the ghost of John Belushi yeah and
I felt that's what John Belushi would do
many just go in steal a car get some
friends and just it's like that's what I
want see Slimer do but I agree that a he
looked weird and why me and Slimer right
but and be female I'm like just I just
want to know what their story is where
do they come from
well well as far as like the ghosts were
concerned I felt some of them were
really well done and then some of them
like the more ghosts they had I felt
like the worse it got I was like the
first ghosts they had the woman I'm like
that's what haunted wanted ghosts should
have looked like like she was beautiful
I loved the colors that they used for
the ghosts I felt they was really unique
and it set it apart from the original
and I thought she was just creepy yes
the whole opening sequence was really
you a lot of effects when you face by
the way why go in the basement say like
we look something's like oh why don't go
in the base great open I do want to talk
about the villain in this movie okay
good I think we're all in agreement
it's no dr. Jana Janos beautiful or goes
my god that kind of vibe where it was
like this crazy dude that really wants
to bring about the destruction of the
city because he gets no respect I
thought they were gonna build him up to
be something different yeah because I'm
talking to himself in the mirror I'm
like oh he's possessed there's a bigger
bad like good god and then I thought
when he like killed himself by holding
on to the machinery and yeah the real
ghost was gonna burst forth he was gonna
just awesome reveal not blow you just
not just died and I found one when there
when the Ghostbusters are with him in
that room I I felt there was potential
first because I would have loved to see
his insecurities come out and like when
they're talking to him and they're like
we know how you feel you know we've been
outcast too you know you don't have to
be like this I would have loved to for
him to have a moment of contemplation to
think about his actions you know that
could have given him some death or for
him to be a bigger man yeah but they
there was more they could have done with
him in a couple different directions and
they didn't do any of it I felt you
either had to make this guy really
awesome evil you know like Gozer or
awesome evil or you gotta make a really
pathetic and goofy you know like Janos
or something like that you know that
would have been funny you know if like
all this chaos and everything is just
caused by this one a-hole who was
bullied that should be very funny but
they're trying to do like this
in-between and it just doesn't work for
either into a point where we're like
wait how does he know this stuff why did
he come across these things but even his
look it's got just a normal guy but not
like a funny teehee ha ha guy boring and
so weird Bell hoppy
and then he got all the knowledge from
reading their book yeah he he knew stuff
they barely even knew right like they
talked about the meridians thing they
never talked about that in their book
because she thought it wasn't real so if
he was he doing extra homework exactly
there was something up but I did like
the possession then of Hemsworth you
know Kevin being able to go bad because
we got like two sides to see of him from
the goofy - yeah you just watch
no regrets here we get that now I can't
be the point thing with like gozar and
Vigo is that they weren't given like you
know a ton of screen time of you got
more but there was kind of this buildup
and there was like they know what's it
show they knew what to say they knew
what to show and it built up to
something especially what goes there
yeah they just can't build it you know
it's like Sauron from Lord of the Rings
man they build it up and they let you
they give you just the right little bits
of information that that's all you need
and you like the mystery of it we're at
this one I don't care what this guy she
wasn't a strong villain now yeah and the
thing that like every time you see him
somebody in the background mentions oh
that guy he's so pathetic
they repeated that so many times and I'm
like okay give us a show don't tell all
you're doing is saying how how sad and
pathetic he is and but he's not that sad
and pathetic he's just talking in a
mirror like everyone people do that
whole thing in the basement of this
hotel and no one knew about it yeah
because he's the janitor yeah let's go
back again to Kevin so is he a secretary
or a graphic designer or web developer I
was that's that's one of the faults of
like Paul Feig directing of like The
Improv is awesome and it's really funny
and you get some really natural quippy
back-and-forth dialogue but then you get
like weird plot holy things really like
wheat so this was a cold interview or he
came in with the graphics already
designed that part was a little
confusing
it wasn't your biggest problem own
beforehand and that he said he was he
could he could design him a logo so
although I do be Ghostbuster right like
just go through boobs like right here
that look really good really good it
really gets to the point you get that
there girl
Buster's I know no one has realized that
yet but I did you you didn't know the
Ghostbusters I don't see I do not see
genders actually the female Slimer count
looks like that goes through the morning
when he possessed Chris Hemsworth he
started manufacturing ghosts cuz he had
superpowers and he created the female
Slimer and brought her to life well
let's do final thoughts Heather what
were her final thoughts about the film
anything else he wanted to talk about
well like I said I didn't think it was
great but I didn't think it was awful I
really felt that there are some jokes
that landed and were hilarious but the
ones that didn't land were almost Ock
where they're like it was like crickets
silence crickets silence like bad bad I
feel like it had a lot of potential to
go somewhere I feel like a lot of things
were built up and then just didn't go
anywhere like we said with the villain
or even like with her ghost girl story I
thought more I was gonna yeah like there
are so many things that could have
happened that they were just like build
it up and we're gonna ignore it I wonder
if we're gonna get like a cool
alternative edit of this where it's like
almost a completely different film where
we get some of the they cut out
that be curious yeah yeah cuz I feel
like they're like I said earlier there
are so many hands that must have been in
it from like Sony that you can feel that
you could feel that bits and parts were
cut out and taken out and rearranged and
mandated to be in here like now you have
to add in dan Aykroyd like it just felt
like it was cut up in piece and well I
think to me a sort of shows that it's
like it is kind of doing its job a
little bit cuz when you said that an
alternate version I'm like I would watch
that we now have one with Batman versus
Superman where I'm like and I didn't
hate that the only things very good and
I'm no interest in seeing them just like
just no nothing like I just wasn't that
interested we're with this one even
though like you sorts of town problems
it's like I like to see what else they
were going
because it's just interesting enough to
me right where it could have gone if so
when you do not have its hands all of it
or arm a there's some good cuts again
the dance sequence yeah well for me I'm
gonna kind of do a little anecdote so
what I don't know like I'm assuming you
maybe had a similar experience but when
during like the final fight sequence and
you have Kate McKinnon and she's like
licking the guns and she's going and
she's kicking ass you see all the
Ghostbusters doing it I got this really
just happy excited feeling because I
will say as a woman we don't have a lot
of all female action ensembles in fact
it's the only ones I can really think of
are like Jem and the Holograms or Josie
because it's like where they're a band
colored girls they in the past 30 years
and their guys have a lot of those and
we haven't grown up in the same thing
like when I was growing up I was told
the Ghostbusters choice were for girls
I was supposed to play the secretary
when we would play elementary school and
now like a generation of girls are gonna
be growing up thinking and knowing they
can be a Ghostbuster and so for me that
just filled me with so much joy and that
does you know that is my own bias as a
woman that's on my own personal feeling
and experience I don't think there's
anything wrong with that but I think
it's just way overdue for women to be
able to have that same experience that
men have had for as long as I've been
alive well and I think with you know I'm
here in all these I'm seeing pictures
and these experiences of like you know
kids running around both boys and girls
dressed as Ghostbusters you know but
dancing to the song run up and down the
aisles you know trying to catch ghosts
and stuff like that and you know whether
or not like even it turns out I hated
this movie I couldn't stand it you know
it wasn't funny or something I mean how
am I gonna argue with that I mean I
can't be like you know no that's bad
come on go join the other girl teams
there's like what five you know
something like that where you know or if
you're in a team there's always like one
or two girls or women in there and stuff
like that I mean this is all-aware if
you count how many ones that are like
all guys there's a lot or majority of
them are guys so yeah I kind of agree
even at this movie like you know turn
out to be really bad it's like how can
you look at these pictures of these
girls being dressed up
let's catch ghosts you know and as a
team and you can get a lot of them and
stuff and be like no bad movies you know
I mean I think that's great too honestly
I'll be honest guy characters has never
stopped me from dressing up as many of
you already know I grew up playing
Ghostbusters and dressing as
Ghostbusters as I never stopped me and
I'm still so so excited to have that end
fight sequence also shout out to overly
expressive facials everywhere thank you
yeah like some of us have faces the do
weird and they're action-packed and
awesome so yeah it was it was really
really cool to have my female
ghostbusters I've been waiting forever I
feel like right now I mean even though
there was like backlash when people
heard the news it just it didn't help
that they've been talked about
Ghostbusters 3 for a year it was just
like no entirely new cast oh by the way
they're all women it's like I just
everything about the pillow up in the
market in this movie I'm just like man
that was that was done but I feel like
yeah this is kind of like at least when
I was growing up kind of like what you
said there was absolutely no girls can
play with boy toys and you know boys can
play with girl toys and stuff I mean you
know not only do we have girls doing
that anyway but we also have boy boys
were watching my little pony yeah you
know that was unheard of yeah when I was
growing up and I think that's phenomenal
so I think it's kind of cool that we're
and they for any other reason just the
possibilities like let's see what
happens let's try sort of the various
type of things we can do with this and I
just I like possibilities and I like
opportunities I like seeing where this
kind of stuff can go on I like that
we're now taking bad so they have more
and more and more you know that there
can be backlash you know about it and
stuff like that from either direction
but I like that these opportunities are
there you know and it's it's just there
and it wasn't louse growing up and I
think that's so cool that like now it's
allowed and it's becoming popular and
people are throwing money at because
they're saying hey this is good enough
it can make money at sample mm-hmm so
give us more merchandise so we can throw
more money in excess Cooper fall out boy
Ghostbuster songs please we all agree
five different versions of the song okay
yeah yeah I mean it's catchy but so I
brought a pic of the week this week on
that no the week week IDW ghostbusters
comics and a lot of them are on the
comiXology app actually on the unlimited
if you have the subscription to
comixology you can read a lot of the
Ghostbusters titles on there
specifically I'm gonna Gary you towards
the happy horror days series it's about
four issues I think there's a Halloween
there's a Dia de los Muertos there's a
Christmas and New Year's Eve and they
all sort of talk about these boogie men
that are trying to get children and
possess them or get them to like do
other things to bring out ghosts and
it's a really really cool little little
series in there so definitely check that
out and if you like the female ghost
Foresters guess what extreme
Ghostbusters including the comics has a
couple of female Ghostbusters I don't
know if some of you didn't know this if
you were shocked by the idea of a female
Ghostbusters issue you might be a little
behind with Griffin and agent Ortiz
that's already going on just so you know
so yeah definitely check that out if you
want a comic book to read and let us
know what you thought of the film for
sure make sure to follow us all on
social media other where can we find you
I um you can find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse or Instagram at a Troops
we're gonna see a lot of nice wedding
pics on there sooner when you got
married
how wedding or no wedding crazy as your
Pinterest right now because mine is like
way overloaded or yeah yeah it's out of
control only person on Pinterest they
think that doesn't have a wedding y'all
can find me on Twitter at Beth elder Ken
you can also find shark jumping on
YouTube it's youtube.com slash shark
jumping show we're in the middle of our
summer series called once a pilot where
we talk about field TV pilots and when
we come back with our regular series in
October it might be election related
because it turns out a certain
presidential candidate has been on
television that's nice yeah I'm pretty
sure his life is on television oh what's
he using Doug who are you he's right
there he's very angry ah you guys know
where to find me Twitter Facebook
Instagram Pinterest if you don't feel
like looking at wedding stuff cuz I
ain't got it yeah a lot of Ghostbusters
stuff I'm there oh my god the cosplay
on my Pinterest is insane like that
too much too much um and probably too
much Ghostbusters - yeah definitely
so check it out um thanks for joining us
today let us know what you thought of
the movie yourself if you're going to
see it if you're not gonna go see it why
don't you go see it why not go see it
tell us what you think and definitely go
make sure to check out our Facebook page
at facebook.com
awesome comics show give us a like
thanks for liking this video thanks for
subscribing and thanks for watching guys
and sharing up a difference for all of
us here at awesome comics I'm Ayanna
Wade and we'll see you in the next page